another thing dr bright is not allowed  to do at the scp foundation if a mind  controlling scp is discovered it is to  be turned over to the proper authorities  it is not to be used to advance himself  or others higher in the foundation look  we've always wanted to be more  persuasive people maybe it's about  getting a new job or a raise or  convincing your buddies to see the movie  you really want to see at the theater  rather than the steven seagal movies  they always insist on but dr wright  using mind controlling scps to help  advance himself at the foundation or  making dr konraki pee his pants so that  he can take his projects while dr  konraki is put on mandatory mental  health leave is simply not acceptable  professional conduct isn't dr bride  anomalously powerful enough already we  really don't need him gaining the power  to control the human mind it just won't  end well